Speaker 1: Hey, this is just out of
this world whacked. Donald Trump is now
saying to Republican voters if
the so-called fraud isn't fixed
for the 2022 and 2024 elections, Republicans
shouldn't even vote. To which I say absolutely.
I actually I. I would never go out and
say, don't vote because it goes against my
beliefs about participation in democracy to tell
people to stay home. I just wouldn't feel right.
But if Trump wants to do it and say to his
Republican followers, Don't vote by all means
that that sounds great to me. So
let's talk about what's going on.
Donald Trump tells Republicans not to vote in
22 or 24 in a new statement that he would have
posted on Twitter himself if his account wasn't
permanently suspended for inciting violence.
Former President Trump urged supporters not
to vote in the two upcoming elections. If
the Republican Party doesn't quote, solve the
supposed voter fraud that he has falsely claimed
precipitated his loss to President Joe Biden.
Donald Trump's full statement published to
the desk of Donald Trump on his website,
says If we don't solve the presidential
election fraud, that's capitalized. Guy's fraud
is capitalized. If we don't solve the presidential
election fraud of 2020, which we have thoroughly
and conclusively documented, that's not true.
Republicans will not be voting in 22 or 24. It is
the single most important thing for Republicans to
do now. It's grammatically ambiguous whether he
says the most important thing to do is to solve
the fraud, or the most important thing to do is
not to vote in twenty two or twenty four. If the
fraud is not solved now, there's two stories
here. One is, is Trump publishing this just
a distraction? And you might say, Well, David,
a distraction from what? There is a new report
from the House Oversight Committee, which we will
talk about later in the show, which found that
Donald Trump received millions of dollars from
foreign governments through the Trump hotels,
hid his debts and hid his losses. It's an insane
blockbuster report, so part of it would be
maybe Trump is saying this to distract from that
story, and we'll talk about that later. The second
part here is that this is the way that narcissists
behave. Quite frankly, if your parents say,
Hey little Donny, it's time to go home. Let's
leave the sandbox now. Donny is the type of kid
who would poop in the sandbox to shut it down so
nobody else can play in the sandbox. When Trump
is losing at an interview, like when he's not
doing well in an interview, he's asking questions
that are making him look bad. He walks out or he
attacks the reporter. When he's losing elections,
he says they're fake. And now he's telling people
not to vote actually laughed. I was thinking about
when, during a press briefing when Donald
Trump did a press briefing as president
and he was asked, What do you say to people who
are watching you right now and are scared? This
was when COVID deaths were skyrocketing
in 2020, and Trump says, I would say,
you're a terrible reporter. That's what I would
say. This is how he behaves. And he is saying,
I didn't. They didn't give me. They didn't
let me become president for four more years.
So I'm just going to try to ruin it for everybody.
Republicans didn't work hard enough to steal
the election for me. Nobody did. And so now I'm
going to say, don't vote and ruin everything for
the party, which I think is great. I think it's
great now. It's it's a it's a very dire message,
in a sense, in terms of being a threat to the
Republican Party, Trump saying either get behind
me and support all this crazy stuff I'm doing and
saying, or I'm going to actively try to destroy
the party by telling our voters not to vote
in 2022 and 2024. It's like a Trump way or the
highway sort of thing. And I absolutely love it.
Like I said, I cannot in good conscience myself
tell people, Don't vote, don't participate.
It's it's it's a form of voter suppression.
I won't do it. But if Trump is telling
them by all means, listen to the guy,
if you still follow him, if you trust him, if you
believe in him, prove it by listening to what he's
saying. These are the sorts of techniques
that would really only work to manipulate
morons and dolts, quite frankly. I mean, let's
be a little more polite. Low information voters.
Ignorant individuals. But if this is what
he's doing, let them have at it. And I guess,
you know, to some degree, Trump must see
voting in twenty two as acknowledging that
the 2020 election was legitimate. I don't even
know that that's really the case. I think many
Republicans would vote in twenty two without
acknowledging that 2020 was legit. For Trump,
it appears that way. And so he's trying to own
the libs by saying, Don't vote on us, please
show us. I challenge these Republicans. Show us
how strong you are by doing what Trump says and
not voting in 2022 and 2024. I won't suggest it.
But if Trump saying it, go with it. I welcome it.
And the real question is, will they listen to
him? Will they listen to him? Let us know. Your
thoughts will have more coverage of this bizarre,
but quite frankly, welcome statement from Trump
on the show's Instagram at David Pakman
show on Instagram. Find us there!